et nous accueillons notre invité du
samedi 20 heures ce soir henri borlant
bontia
henri borlant le 21 juillet 1942 votre
père votre frère votre soeur et vous
étiez déportés au camp d'auschwitz
birkenau
vous aviez 15 ans vous vivrez la shoah
pendant trois ans échappant de justesse
à la famine aux maladies aux chambres à
gaz avant de vous évader en avril 1945
aujourd'hui vous êtes le dernier
survivant des 6000 enfants de moins de
16 ans déporté à auschwitz en 1942 vous
dites je suis le seul à pouvoir en
parler je n'ai donc pas le droit de me
taire
[Musique]
henri borlant rebond soir vous publié
aux éditions du seuil merci d'avoir
survécu un livre témoignage ou vous
raconter comment vous avez été déporté à
auschwitz à l'âge de 15 ans et l'horreur
de la shoah mais reprenons les choses au
commencement vous êtes né le 5 juin 1927
ce qui nous fait 84 ans votre père aaron
est un juif russe originaire d'une
petite bourgade près de dessins sur la
mer noire tailleur de métier il a
déserté l'armée du tsar alors qu'il
effectué son service militaire son rêve
c'était la france où la moitié de la
population prenait fait et cause pour la
défense d'un obscur officier juif nommé
alfred dreyfus à paris aaron rencontre
rachel juive russe elle aussi ils se
marient en 1916 ils auront dix enfants
la famille ben ne roule pas sur l'or
c'est la crise des années 30 et vous dit
à partir du 20 du mois nous achetions du
paa crédit on était comme tout le monde
dans ce milieu populaire où nous vivions
nom était heureux ouais
quant à la religion la famille borlant
n'est pas pratiquante mise à part
circoncision bar mitzvah bouzid le
sentiment qui prédominait était celui
d'être français
fier français avant des juifs mes
parents l'avaient voulu et ils ont
demandé et lorsqu'ils ont obtenu la
naturalisation
ils ont ils ont été très heureux il
était si heureux qu'il souhaitait que la
famille restée en russie les rejoignent
pour eux ce qui était malheureux c'était
ce qui était restée là bas rhin
en août 1939 la menace de guerre se
précise par crainte de bombardements
vous êtes envoyé donc en maine et loire
vous quitter paris avec votre mère
enceinte votre père reste dans la
capitale en septembre
vous faites votre rentrée scolaire dans
le maine et loire c'est là que vous
apprenez
que le peuple juif est responsable de la
mort du christ et en même temps c'est le
celui qui fait la classe qui nous
apprend à compter à lire là et donc
c'est on met pas en doute que oui
raconte oui
école catholique alors juin 1946 la
débâcle votre père rejoint la famille
dans le maine et noir ils trouvent du
travail et là vous avez une vie assez
heureuse pendant un moment
heureuse très heureuse ouais
alors un prêtre le professeur de
catéchisme conseils à vos parents de
vous faire baptiser la religion
catholique vous passionne vous souhaitez
même devenir prêtre mais c'est
impossible parce que vous êtes juive
je crois qu'on pensait que personne
savait que nous étions juifs
et on tait parce que ça se sache on
je sais que ce n'est pas ce n'était pas
le moment ce n'est pas le lieu c'était
pas l'époque 1 vous n'êtes pas devenu
prêtre en 1941 obéissant la loi votre
père vous déclare comme juif à la
préfecture il pensait que le fait d'être
baptisé vous protégerez je le crois oui
en 1942 angers est occupée par la
wehrmacht la gestapo s'y installent et
le 15 juillet 1942 donc la veille de la
rafle du vel d'hiv un camion se gare
devant chez vous soldats frappent à la
porte ils embarquent tous les juifs qui
ont entre 15 et 50 ans je venais d'avoir
15 ans un mois auparavant
mon frère bernard avait 17 ans on a
envoyé chercher dans la ferme où il
travaillait il est arrivé avec ses
sabots aux pieds il a été déporté avec
ses sabots
ma soeur theunis 21 ans et ma mère qui
avait 42 ans au début vous croyez que
c'est pour aller travailler en fait le
21 juillet 1942 après 48 heures sous les
verrous votre père votre frère votre
soeur et vous être embarqué dans des
wagons à bestiaux
60 à 80 par wagon les portes et les
fenêtres hermétiquement fermé le train
mettra des heures avant de partir de
quitter la gare j'ai chaud vous pouvez
même pas vous allongez tellement il ya
de monde ment dans ses trains vous
n'avez pas du tout conscience à l'époque
de ce qui vous attend
on ne pouvait pas imaginer qu'on nous
avait arrêté pour nous exterminer le
fait que sur les lices c'était seulement
ceux qui avaient entre 15 et 50 ans ça
laissait penser que c'était le haut pour
aller travailler et puis à un moment ils
reprennent votre mère et il met votre
père à la place donc vous dites bâle
c'est bien la preuve que c'est pour la
vague et parce que sinon il aurait
laissé maman so lu ment absolument oui
le voyage va durer trois jours trois
jours de cauchemar vous dites les gens
se marchaient dessus
et on y avait un baquet dans un coin il
fallait faire ses besoins devant tout le
monde il faisait chaud sai bas qui a
débordé
bref c'était extrêmement pénible à vivre
on était pressé d'arriver ouais alors au
cours du voyage écrivant un mot que vous
jetez par la lucarne maman chérie il
paraît que nous partons en ukraine pour
faire les moissons ce mot est ramassée
par un cheminot es etc sera remis à
votre votre maman serait absolument
extraordinaire et nous on parlera à la
fin de la guerre qu'on voulait quand
vous la retrouverez
malheureusement c'est pas en ukraine que
vous arrivez c'est à birkenau
quand vous arrivez pas de gare paquet
dans la campagne vous avez d'abord un
sentiment de délivrance parce
qu'évidemment on vous sort de ces de ses
wagons mais très vite vous réalisez vous
arrive en enfer
parmi les soldats il y a des bagnards ya
des gens avec des dés ce que nous ont
appelés les pyjamas rayés ouais donc on
a vraiment un sentiment d'horreur
absolue alors qu on était content d'être
arrivé en fait c'était la fin du
cauchemar et tout à coup c'est
dramatique c'est l'horreur c'est l'écrit
les coûts les chiens on crie désordre
dans une langue dont on confond pas un
mot et déjà des coûts
etc c'est la terreur où on est on est
terrorisée on
comprend pas ce qui se passe dans l'es16
font le tri les femmes enceintes les
vieux les boiteux en tout ça repart dans
des camions là vous savez même pas ce
qu'ils deviennent en fait et quand vous
arrivez dans le camp déjà on vous inspec
tenue la première fois on a déshabillé
devant tout le monde on est incrédule on
dit c'est pas possible
et puis les coups commencent à pleuvoir
et ceux qui se déshabille pas assez vite
reçoivent des coups et puis les habits
on
on doit les mettre par terre et il ya
des déportés en tenue de bagnards qui
ramasse et qui mélange on sent qu'on les
reverra plus gré
là vous êtes intégralement rasé et vous
est tatoué on vous tattoo un numéro 51
mille 0,55 sur l'avant bras gauche
voilà
comme au premier jour
on vous donne des vêtements qui sont en
général salle user déchirer vous
comprenez qu'ils sont passés rapidement
à l'étude c'est encore humide mais en
fait c'est les vêtements des morts qu'on
veut qu'on vous donne hélas les soldats
vous mettre à l'épreuve ils vous mettent
en rang sans bouger pendant des heures
et temps en temps ils ont tué
pour vous montrer que votre vie n'a
aucune valeur
on nous dit d'ici n'ayez aucune illusion
vous ne sortirez que par les cheminées
vous avez cette odeur de chair brûlée
qui qui est partout
alors les soldats vous épuise en rang
vous en faire des travaux inutiles c'est
évidement de creuser un trou et puis le
lendemain de leur bouche et puis ensuite
de causer un trouble de leur bouche et
enfin des trucs qui servent absolument à
rien juste pour vous fatiguer pour vous
prouver quoi
et toute la journée dehors ouais
l'avastin climat très continental fait
très chaud l'été très froid l'hiver on
doit courir on est chaussée avec des des
semelles de bois rigide avec toile au
dessus c'est tout à fait un commode et
on reçoit des coups parce qu'on s'arrête
on reçoit des coups parce qu'on renverse
on reçoit des coups parce qu'on n'a pas
remplies ou pas ce concours pas assez
vite oui on vous fait agrandir le camp
de birkenau donc évidemment au prix de
centaines de morts cirque eux on vous
demande de construire la machine qu'ils
destinaient à vous tuer et les
crématoriums et les chambres à gaz
ensuite vous partez à auschwitz a
lorsqu'il plus terrible à auschwitz et
la fin c'est à dire qu'à midi vous avez
un litre de soupe le soir les deux cents
grammes de pain avec une petite rondelle
de saucisson ou un petit margarine on a
faim jour et nuit la nuit on rêve de
nourriture ouais et puis les gens maigri
maigri à vue d'oeil et puis à la
dysenterie or ce qui est terrible avec
la dysenterie c'est que vous avez
interdiction d'aller aux toilettes mais
ceux qui sentent mauvais sont battus
on est sale on est couvert de plus alors
on a par moments on a accès à l'eau pour
se laver mais là aussi il faut jouer des
coudes parce que
s'il est plus les plus costauds qui
arrive à l'eau et puis à la sélection
pour les chambres à gaz évidemment vous
avertissent et les nouveaux arrivants
mais ils veulent pas y croire
au début on ne peut pas on peut pas y
croire ouais
ouais
ensuite vous est transféré à ordre ouf
d'où vous finirez par vous évadez vous
même tout seul avec votre pote bevin le
3 avril
et quand vous arrivez en france vous
réalisez que ce que vous avez vécu n'est
pas racontable en fait parce que votre
récit est proprement insupportable dit
le cerveau se défend et se protège
je n'éprouve pas la nécessité de le
raconter ce que j'arrive dans une
famille traumatisée
mon père est mort mon frère ma soeur
sont morts mes grands parents et les
parents de ma mère
ont été déportés sont morts là bas aussi
une de ses soeurs également donc ils ont
souffert beaucoup tu te sens pas utile
ni nécessaire ni possible de leur dire
ce qui s'est passé parce que ce serait
les faire souffrir inutilement euro
et donc en famille on n'en parle pas
alors aujourd'hui vous témoigner parce
que dites vous la shoah n'a pas vacciner
le monde
on avait espéré on disait plus jamais ça
et puis on a depuis la fin de la guerre
il ya eu d'autres crimes de masse il ya
eu d'autres génocides
et voilà je crois qu'il faut continuer à
raconter à dire à faire savoir
alors quand dieudonné reçoit le célèbre
négationniste faurisson
sur la scène du zénith
vous qui avez vu les chambres à gaz vous
qui avez failli aller vous réagissez
comme ans mais justement c'est pour ça
que c'est pour ça que je témoigne c'est
pour ça que les anciens déportés
témoigne c'est pour que les gens sachent
et qu'ils prennent pas à la légère
quand il ya des élections
et qu' ils comprennent que est clair il
a été élu démocratiquement absolument et
que aujourd'hui le front national ce
sont souvent
ceux qui ont la nostalgie de cette
époque
du gouvernement de vichy de ce régime et
on doit se prémunir contre ça et il faut
à tout prix empêcher le retour donc il
faut avoir conscience du danger pour
pour éviter que ça se reproduise
[Musique]
ce qu'il faut dire c'est que
vous êtes marié avec une allemande
anti-nazie et que vous êtes trésor et
avec elle je veux dire ça avant de
terminer la saluer
merci d'avoir survécu c'est le type de
mots clés voilà
merci à mes parents et pour être sûr de
ne rien rater de inler 10 tubes abonnez
vous y mettez un peu de bleu